I feel different obviously but yeah it's
amazing
but if it's some Imam who thinks that
you know women should cover themselves
up like they look like Jabba the Hutt or
what is it was it Boba Fett whichever
one whatever it is please direct your
hate mail to Joe Rogan [ __ ] it bring it
on see what this tells everyone who sees
me is what stands before you is a woman
of enormous strength enormous courage
and integrity this woman will not lie
she will not cheat she will not deceive
she will be the best employer the best
employee the best friend the best
adviser the best counselor
that's a Muslim woman but sadly most
people won't actually ask us and I find
it quite patronizing that the majority
of people around us the media and
politicians all find it acceptable to
speak on behalf of us Muslim women
without asking us for our views in the
first place the reality is this myth is
at complete odds with the evidence I
mean if the hijab was a symbol of
women's day of subordinates then how do
we explain the fact that the highest
group of converts to Islam both in the
UK and the u.s. are women were many of
these women wear the hijab without
having any male relatives to force them
into it
and if the hijab was an issue to the
majority of Muslim women then how do we
explain the results of the 2005 Gallup
survey were Muslim women in 8 countries
including Egypt and Pakistan were asked
to describe what they resented most
about the societies they live in and the
majority in each country stated
political and economic corruption as
being their greatest concerns whilst the
hijab the so-called halt of subjugation
was not mentioned once can trust her and
it's a warning oh yeah it looks up here
and it tells to everybody what stands
before you is a woman who knows her
Worth she knows her value she is not a
toy so don't even try to play with her
where the very liberal values of freedom
have created the viewpoint of a woman as
being a sexual exploit where her beauty
is
everyone's business from eating
disorders to the rampant levels of
sexual harassment rape and domestic
violence were according to Home Office
statistics an incident of domestic
violence is reported to the police every
minute here in the UK is this really the
value and elevation that women seek this
is a woman you take serious law
prohibits exploitation of anyone and
Bill's the correct viewpoint of the
woman as being an honor to be valued for
her character and her intellect over her
physical appearance because the prophet
muhammad salallahu alayhi wasalam said
the world and all things in it are
precious but the most precious thing is
a virtuous woman mmm
and he has a problem with that yeah you
know in the language that he the
language that's the thing the language
that's that's the thing he says you mean
he's making fun of Muslim women who are
choosing to cover their hair because one
it's a religious requirement and two
they're doing it out of modesty they're
not the first people in the past or even
today who cover out of modesty I mean
women wear hijab when they go outside of
the house I mean who are not even Muslim
can you equate they absolutely walking
on naked yeah exactly they're covering
themselves there's a type of modesty
that's there right but he's going and
saying you know they're dressed like
Jabba the Hutt you know I didn't really
get that example then he corrected and
said oh there's a dress like Boba Fett
not really never as it's not it's not
it's not cool you know so and especially
not in the current climate yeah where
you know you got France just passed a
law that forbade Muslim women from
wearing their quote/unquote burqini
which is like you know their hijab that
they're gonna go and swim and the beach
with it's forbidden they're not allowed
to even practice that you want to talk
about freedom of religion or freedom you
know to criticize all that freedom that
we keep hearing about they can't even go
to the beach they're not you're not
allowed to dress how you want to dress
right and then to make fun of them and
use some Star Wars figures and all of
that stuff it's it's not cool it on
bullying is an epidemic now yeah it's
it's a major epidemic and you
specifically Muslim women who are being
bullied I mean there are leagues not
cool it happened to many of my friends I
know personally my wife's friends they
go out in the supermarket people not
only give them stairs they actually like
insults at them you know why you wearing
that rag over your head why are you
doing this they don't even feel
comfortable going to the grocery store
and this is not some exaggerated feeling
this is fact-based right
Muslim women have had their hijab ripped
off from them and this is not isolated
incident this is happening on a major in
a significant level to just throw it off
and say you know what well we have the
freedom to criticize your religion but
you don't have the freedom to dress how
you want to address you have to adopt
our understanding our principles of what
modesty or of what what freedom of dress
should be like right that's exactly the
type of narrow mindedness that he's
criticizing in all these other aspects
so you got to be consistent yeah you
have to be consistent in what you're
saying
there was a Jewish another Jewish
academic and this is interesting this is
what he said dr. Norman Finkelstein he
said when Europeans came to North
America the thing they said about the
Native American is that they were so
barbaric because they walked around
naked the European women at that time
they were wearing three layers of
clothes then they came to North America
and decided that the Native Americans
were backward because they were all
rocked around naked and he continues and
he says and now we walk around naked and
we say that the Muslims are backward
because they wear some so much so much
clothes can you imagine anything more
barbaric banning women from wearing
headscarves so this is a Jewish man yeah
right absolutely who's got you know
who's has friends with Muslims we're
friends with him I mean these are people
working together to some obvious facts
when I think about that so he's talking
about when they came over and they were
waiting pretty much hijab yep if you
look at the eighty exactly exactly and
they were walking around naked now
they're trying to exactly that's really
the problem the core the crux of this
problem is this holier-than-thou
attitude yeah right it's like you know
looking at them these are less you know
less people than us that they're lesser
than us they're uncivilized there are
backwards in one of his you know things
he said him or one of his guests said
Islam is 500 years behind what is that
supposed to mean like this idea of well
we've changed our cultural norms we
started dressing a different way we've
even changed our morals and now you guys
are behind now you know you should be
following exact
what we what we're doing we set the
trends and if you don't follow the trend
then you're backwards you're behind you
need to catch up this this idea this is
like that Orientalism idea that you know
Edward Sayid was mentioning in his book
kind of deconstructing this idea of
people who are in a position to go and
like classify others into a certain
frame thinking that you need to be like
us when you're uncivilized we're
civilized we need to come and civilize
you there needs to be a little bit more
nuanced than that we're trying to
understand people and Joe's a bright guy
I mean he mentions when he starts to
think objectively like he says
professionally wisely and he sees like
and he mentions this about why why would
people be doing some of the things right
and he talks about their natural
resources being stolen he talks about
the dehumanization and and and and
that's what really gave me hope you know
when I saw when I saw him talking about
that in his clip to the suppression of
the people that live in these places
where their natural resources being
stolen and by the war machine right
which is undeniable undeniable what's
going on in Iraq or in Afghanistan how
much of it how much of the hustle has to
do with the natural resources whether
they be the poppy fields whether they be
the minerals in Afghanistan whether it's
the oil in Iraq undeniable that these
people are being sure for sure they're
subject to the war machine that's coming
in to steal the resources and that
that's that's something that people are
aware of and you see these images of
these people and these Islamic countries
that are dying that are getting bombed
on and and also the D humanism that
they're subjected to by a lot of people
that are trying to justify this right
these wars that that is the only thing
that makes sense to me he's like yeah
okay I understand Muslims around the
world their resources are being taken
from them they're being oppressed
they're being dehumanized he says we're
not gonna deny what's happening in Iraq
what's happening in Afghanistan it's
horrible what's happening and then he
kind of hints at the answer that he's
almost there he almost figures out why
Islamophobia is a problem why we
shouldn't be you know doing all this
disrespect and all of that but then
right when he's there and he's saying
you know that
could play a role than his guests you
know somehow diverts him and takes him
off wanting some other tangent and then
that thought is just gone so I think I
think Joe is he's searching and I think
he's trying to find out but he's just
it's like someone who has a problem an
addiction or whatever they're trying to
get rid of but all the friends around
them they keep reinforcing that behavior
and even though they're trying to get
out until they kind of clear their way
from those friends and try and associate
with other people spend a little bit
time with others they're not gonna be
able to get out because they're always
being sucked back into that bad habit
that they have